well you posted this photo on what's
going on here okay so that's Helen Han
and that is Zac Efron with the photo
bomb in the corner 12 year-old Zakir I
went to a program called sisa at Cal
arts here in California when I was 15
Zak and I were two of the youngest
people went and Helen Hunt was my acting
teacher Zak was in my cooler acting
group and he was it's like his first
time away from home and it was my first
time away from home and it was like this
amazing summer where Helen Hunt taught
me like Joan of Arc monologues like it
was amazing sac made it way younger than
I did so he was a big huge star before
she broke girls ever premiere does he
had a shirt on that picture we just rare
rare but yeah what Zac you're working
hard for it yes you look great honey you
know that you're acting coat that's
insane I know I haven't actually gotten
a run into her she's one of the people I
would have loved to over the years
actually get to be like actually you
were my teacher and you were amazing but
I've never gotten to I haven't run into
her at anything's like my home but she
was wonderful and I learned some of that
cool thing that was super cool I will
not stop talking until you subscribe to
my youtube channel that's right and I
could talk a lot seriously not gonna
stop yep still here not going anywhere I
see you don't walk away from this